Netflix might be the top dog when it
comes to online video subscription
services but Amazon Prime video is
mounting a real challenge to that title
in fact Amazon Prime actually has more
subscribers though many of them haven't
even checked out the company's video
service if you're one of those people or
you're just wondering what exactly they
have to offer here's a look at some of
the hidden gems available on Amazon
Prime instant video Paradise Lost the
child murders at Robin Hood Hills if you
love true crime dramas then don't miss
your chance to watch this gripping and
moving documentary about one of the most
notorious multiple killings in recent
history Paradise Lost chronicles the
tale of the West Memphis Three three
teenagers tried and convicted for the
murders of three boys in West Memphis
Arkansas I think the cops just can't
find who done it and I got to put it on
somebody it's a chilling look at both
the brutal murders and the witch hunt
that led to convictions against the
three suspects who were finally released
from prison nearly two decades later
so like I'm the West move just boogeyman
little kids will be looking under their
bed before they know to be in a day like
monster Roger Ebert called Charlize
Theron's portrayal of serial killer
Aileen Wuornos in monster one of the
greatest performances in the history of
cinema Theron ended up winning seventeen
awards for the role including the
Academy Award and Golden Globe for Best
Actress with many critics and audience
members failing to even recognize their
and thanks to a truly transformative
performance some real good with people
and I know how to work a Rolodex the
harrowing true crime story isn't for
everyone but if you love quality cinema
it might be for you
Adventureland Jesse Eisenberg Kristen
Stewart Kristen Wiig and Bill Hader
headline adventureland
in a reverend comedy set at a rundown
amusement park at times touching and
sweet at others uproariously funny
Adventureland is a great summer
coming-of-age flick that mixes nostalgia
with offbeat humor to create an
unexpectedly moving movie experience
what the hell of that it's just my life
Selma it is critically acclaimed
historical drama selma takes us on a
journey to 1965 as dr. Martin Luther
King and other voting rights activists
lead protesters on a 54 mile long march
from Selma to Montgomery Alabama by
highlighting racial injustice with these
marches some of which were televised as
troopers beat and attacked the
protesters the disenfranchisement of
black voters finally came to an end
after the passage of the Voting Rights
Act later that year Selma doesn't pull
any punches and dramatically depicts the
brutalization and killing of activists
and innocence in a seminal moment of the
American history that resonates as
strongly now as ever under the skin
Scarlett Johansson delivers a
spellbinding performance in under the
skin as a mysterious alien who preys on
men in Scotland the movie takes on the
aliens perspective of our world and she
exhibits callous disinterest in the
things that make the human experience
unique the urge to comfort a crying baby
savoring the flavor of food or the
simple enjoyment of music and that's the
heart of this film's magnetic draw by
showing the audience our world from an
alien perspective it makes the point
clear that the meaning of everything
really is in the eye of the beholder
bone tomahawk we like Kurt Russell
we love horror films we really love
tombstone so when a director makes a
genre bending West
horror film starring Kurt Russell as a
hard-nosed lawmen who has to defeat a
clan of cannibals it's pretty much
guaranteed that we're gonna lose our
minds over it
bone tomahawk is just as awesome as it
sounds with Russell starring as sheriff
Franklin Hunt who must figure out how to
defeat the cannibals holed up in the
valley of starving men before they can
murder more of the citizens of the small
town he's sworn to defend heck yeah
ex machina if you love science fiction
films about robots or artificial
intelligence but hate they're constantly
rehash plots ex machina is the remedy
you've been searching for this
independent movie takes common science
fiction tropes and turns them upside
down as a computer programmer caleb
accepts an invitation to administer the
Turing intelligence test to a humanoid
robot named Ava what follows is an
intricate plot with elements of sci-fi
or psychological drama and thrills to
keep you entertained and engage through
numerous unexpected twists with
exceptional writing and a stellar
performance by Alicia vikander as Ava ex
machina will keep you at the edge of
your seat and best of all and as dancing
this movie's got everything thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff that we
know you'll love too
you